are you excited for the next star wars
battlefront well in a couple weeks
you'll be able to get your first look at
star wars battlefront 2 no not the one
that came out in 2005 it's a brand new
game from EA anyway I'm Matt and this
gamespot news update is coming to you
from a galaxy far far away the first
trailer for star wars battlefront 2
arrives on April fifteenth at 1130am
Pacific or 230 p.m. eastern it makes its
debut as part of Star Wars Celebration
at a panel called the galaxy wide
premiere of star wars battlefront two
you know subtlety thankfully you don't
have to attend the panel in person to
get a look at the new game as it'll be
streamed online and available on
gamespot as soon as possible make sure
to LIKE and subscribe so you're one of
the first people to see all of the Star
Wars action star wars battlefront 2 is
slated for this year but there's no word
on confirmed platforms however if I was
a betting man I'd say ps4 xbox one and
pc EA has suggested that the sequel will
be a larger more in-depth game that
features a single player campaign and
content from multiple errors of the star
wars franchise we'll keep you updated as
more information is revealed but if you
can't wait for some sci-fi guns
a-blazing action check out our video on
our favorite firearms from Mass Effect
Andromeda
you